as it turns out making a movie about a
weapon that could destroy the world
doesn't mean you can't have a little fun
along the way peculia Murphy though that
fun ended with his dinner that was a
Christopher Nolan film Oppenheimer
foregoes much use of CGI it also heavily
relies on practical sense as many of the
movies Los alamo's sequences were filmed
in the New Mexico desert and has such a
huge cast filled with recognizable names
many people had to be in the area to
shoot at the same time in fact
production on these scenes has been
described as a sorts of summer camp for
the cast and crew especially since there
was very little to do in the vicinity of
the shoot Oppenheimer star Emily Blunt
even told Entertainment Tonight that
more than a few Margaritas were consumed
in the making of their movie still it
made for a good bonding experience blunt
explained there was one hotel and we
were all together and that doesn't
happen normally everyone's in their own
place or you're shooting at home or
everyone's got their own house naturally
being cooped up in the same hotel for an
extended period of time is bound to
result in some friendships being made
what the Oppenheimer shoot wasn't a
summer camp in the strictest sense of
the world there was at least one
communion meeting ground where everyone
got together after all there was also
only one restaurant in the area meaning
it became a popular hang spot for the
cast with one noteworthy exception and
the same Entertainment Tonight interview
Matt Damon said his leg open for
breakfast lunch and dinner and so you
were always it was like the dining hall
you'd go in and you'd see everybody and
so everyone would just end up sitting
together more the cast formed a sense of
camaraderie while shooting the movie
Damon added that Killian Murphy who
plays Jay rubber Oppenheimer himself
wouldn't join them blunt mentions are
Murphy would eat just one almond for
most nights he was losing so much weight
for the part that he just didn't eat
dinner ever the end result is that
Murphy's Oppenheimer looks quite
emaciated throughout much of the film of
course Murphy isn't the first actor to
go to extreme methods in order to lose
weight for a rower Christian Bale
attempted something similar in The
Machinist while Jake Gyllenhaal did the
same for Nightcrawler kylian Murphy
followed in that trajectory foregoing
the cast group meals so that he could
look more like the real J rubber
Oppenheimer he discussed his intention
with his physicality in May when
speaking with the New York Times
mentioning I love acting with my body
and Oppenheimer had a very distinct
physicality and silhouette which I
wanted to get right many on social media
have used a news story to joke about how
Murphy became a real-life almond mom
which is a term used to describe someone
who's perpetually stuck in diet culture
meanwhile others debated whether such
extreme commitment is needed in this day
and age one to the user wrote in a
computer-generated Cinema landscape
there's no reason to eat one almond a
day for a role computers can make John
Goodman look 20 years younger they can
make Killian Murphy look 20 pounds
lighter too while speaking with the
guardian Murphy made sure to note that
he doesn't recommend anyone tried to do
what he did for this part he said you
become competitive with yourself a
little bit which is not healthy I don't
advise her Murphy also insisted that the
weighty lust for the role should not
eclipse the story of the film itself no
doubt His stunning performance as J
Robert Oppenheimer will soon speak for
itself
foreign